dave gettleman the gm of the giants
recently addressed their quarterback
position daniel jones top 10 pick a
couple of years ago still hasn't shown
that he's a true long-term franchise
quarterback but according to gettlemen
for now they're not looking elsewhere
here's what he had to say
we've done the evaluation on him and we
really believe he's the guy
so it's it's no reason to you know no
reason to go look i mean everybody you
know
what we're doing isn't fantasy football
we're not playing we're not doing that
you know we've we've got a conviction on
him he's everything we want
he's got all the physical skills
and again i i say this all the time
you know the guy the kid just finished
his second year
of nfl football all right
how many of us after two years at our
new job
were great
no we all start at point a and we
hopefully get
excuse me hopefully get to point z
but the one common denominator is it
takes time
everybody's gonna understand that we're
we believe in daniel and that's where it
is
yeah
this strikes me as a guy who's telling
the truth
primarily because they're trying to give
this guy a boost they're trying to
support him as much as they can they're
still trying to find out what they have
and a lot of times teams will do that
where they will supply that
that
that extra something and let the world
know that we believe in this guy now it
wasn't over the top but they're giving
him every opportunity now the reality is
he's trying to become the best
quarterback he can be in an era where
you see guys who are quickly becoming
great and quickly showing that they have
it so do you get the five years like you
used to no do you get three years i
guess you do
but chris i feel like it's it's up or
out this year for daniel jones that if
he doesn't get it done this year if he
doesn't prove that he can be a team or a
quarterback that can lead his team to
the playoffs then that's when they start
looking elsewhere next year it is a big
year yes and i think yeah like if it was
another if it was an average year again
this year then i don't know if they
necessarily just you know ditch him but
they'll probably bring in
like a really high-end quality backup
maybe to be a little bit like
competition or if you falter or don't
play the way we want and do all that
then we might have to you know go to
this guy or something that way but at
this point where we stand right now you
don't abandon ship on daniel jones no
way you know first off we can all see
there's a lot of issues you know with
the giants they've not been the perfect
football team we could all see two years
ago when eli manning was taken out of
the game you know and daniel jones got
in that whoa he was clearly better than
eli manning at that time and he could do
some things that eli couldn't now has it
been perfect no
but it's
second year like gettleman said it's two
different systems he's been in and two
years of his nfl career you know the
offensive line's been pretty crappy they
kind of got it going and of course
they've invested in it they got it going
towards the second half of the year and
it looks like it's on the right track
even though i know they let go zeitler
you know yesterday but that's the way
we're in and
you know they're they're start you know
with sacon is hurt evan ingram has
flashes of being awesome but it has
issues there they got darius slayton
okay he's a real good player but they
need another guy too like we always talk
about with these franchise top 10
quarterbacks you know again what do you
expect if you want to make it work make
it work give him some some talent around
him to to accentuate his own talent so
i'm not dead on daniel jones at all it
is a big year yes i wish he would
scramble and get out of the pocket not
be such the statue of liberty in there
sometimes and that leads to the fumbles
and all that but damn there is a lot of
good decisions and high quality throws
and we saw an 80 yard run that not a lot
of quarterbacks in football can do and i
think that's why you keep them and you
still believe in them and going into
year three
i think it was a 75-yard run oh i
thought it was it i thought it was eight
i think it was it was 80 he should have
been 85 for the touchdown that's what it
was yeah it should have been it should
have been what whatever it whatever it
could have been it was about five yards
short of that right
the the the thing that that you pointed
out after his rookie year and hasn't
gotten appreciably better the idea that
the clock in his head yeah he holds it
too long he has to have a better sense
of when to get rid of the ball because
in that process of of of cocking your
arm that's when you get hit and that's
when the ball is most vulnerable to come
out that's something he's got to work on
but you know again
we saw an example with matt rule of
something that is the opposite of honest
we saw
ron rivera being completely honest with
with dave gettleman i'm not quite sure
where it falls because you got to prop
up your quarterback you got to do what
you can to boost your guy and i i think
that they're at least
waiting to see if this year can become
the year he fulfills his promise yeah
yeah i i think so and like like i said i
think there's enough good there to go
whoa we we see enough here that we're
we're not giving up on this yet you know
yeah we got issues but and he's got some
issues that he's got to fix on like you
just mentioned and all that but they're
also going to look and go well some of
those issues are our fault too because
we haven't been able to protect them and
do those type of things as well and
this is the other thing
the
giants their organization in general
i think
the
the coaches they have there who come
from new england
they're not the type of organization or
coaches who just look at it and go oh
it's the quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback quarterback this
is we're going to build a damn team and
we're going to have a system and we hope
our quarterback can be really good
within that but they're not going to sit
there and go oh well he's not patrick
mahomes and we want him to make plays
like desean watson and josh allen and
all those type of things either so
they're i guess more realistic with
those expectations in kind of evaluating
themselves and going wait you know we
like this guy he got a lot of strong
attributes now are we doing our part to
help him that way and i think that joe
judge dave gettleman you know patrick
graham on defense or all those type of
guys who can kind of go wait no no it
hasn't been totally fair for him yet and
we still see the positives and let's
help him out with the rest of the
football team and then maybe we can get
the guy that we really think was worthy
of that number six pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports